what's going on guys in this video i'm
going to be giving my thoughts on the
final chapter of attack on titan which
has now concluded the series after 11
years
i think regardless of how it ended for
me the series was always going to be one
of my favorites
largely due to its originality and the
way the narrative unfolded
in the beginning we were told that
humanity only existed within the walls
and we didn't know where the titans came
from exactly so to see that mystery
slowly unravel and become what it is
today
it was pretty grey to summarize my
feelings on the final chapter without
any spoilers
i would say that it was mostly
satisfying realistic
somewhat wholesome but also really
depressing for a certain person
in this video i'll be explaining how the
final chapter reveals certain things
like how mikoset is the real main
character why eren never truly acquired
freedom
and the true meaning of this scene from
the penultimate chapter in order to do
that i will be going into big spoiler
territory from this point forwards
so if you're an anime only then it is
time to check out now if you haven't
already then be sure to hit that sub
button as we are getting closer to 300k
and drop a like as it does help out the
video okay so obviously the first person
we should talk about is aaron as this
ending confirms several interesting
things about his character
if we go way back to chapter 121 you'll
remember aaron and zeke were going
through grisha's memories
and they stumbled across the crime scene
in which aaron and mikasa had killed
three kidnappers
in aaron's words he said that if someone
was willing to take his freedom
he would not hesitate to take theirs and
that's just the person he's always been
this is why it was always suspicious to
me that when he began the rumbling and
found the true freedom he'd been seeking
he still allowed the alliance to come
and kill him with the power of the
founder
he could have literally stopped them at
any moment but he allowed them to
continue and basically invited them to
come and end his life
thanks to the final chapter we now know
for sure that aaron was indeed holding
back
since he wanted to ensure that his
friends defeated him and became the
saviors of humanity
that might sound cheesy on the surface
but it does make perfect sense
especially when we look at this panel
with his current powers aaron
experiences the past present and future
all at the same time
or to put it in other words the future
cannot be changed
it was always set in stone that the
alliance would defeat him so even though
he wanted to destroy everything
and even though he had the power to do
it he still had to let them beat him
because the future can't be altered
that same logic about not changing the
future is the same reason why aaron used
the founding titan to make sure his
mother was eaten but first let's explain
how that was even possible
when he kissed historia's hand we know
we saw memories from both the past and
future
and when we zoom in on the shards here
we can clearly see that one of those
memories is of bertolt
for those of you that maybe forgot on
the day the warriors attacked bulmaria
the diner fritz titan approached bertolt
but did not eat him
pure titans usually always eat someone
if the chance is available
so it was weird that she walked straight
past him and instead went straight to
the jager household
the finale confirmed that aaron used his
time-transcending powers
to make dinofritz avoid eating bertolt
as if he had died then it would have
seriously messed up the timeline
not only that but he then made diner go
in the direction of his mother so that
she
could be eaten and this was necessary to
give past eren the motivation
to do everything we've seen him do so
far my take on this is that it is a cool
little paradox but it has the knock-on
effect of proving that eren is
essentially a slave
think about it if he truly had free will
there is no chance he would orchestrate
his own mother's death but he did it
because he has no choice
he is a slave to the future and the past
that was set out for him
perhaps that's why he got so pissed off
when armin called him a slave back in
the final season
since in reality that is exactly what he
is he's a guy being forced to act in
certain ways
even when he doesn't want to this is why
it's so ironic
that we got a whole panel of grisha
telling baby aaron that he was free
because this is just not the case he was
forcing in his world to become a titan
shifter
and then those powers will attract him
in this endless cycle of causing his
mother's death
then everything that happens after that
and then growing up to cause his
mother's death again and again and again
it's just a repeating cycle
aaron was never free to deviate from his
eventual fate he was more so following
the future that was laid out for him
based on choices made by others this is
why i do still feel some sympathy for
him despite him being a genocidal maniac
that killed 80
of humanity but if this was real life i
probably wouldn't feel so bad but for
aaron i am willing to make this
exception
now moving on to the full context of his
conversation with armin this was
interesting for several reasons
for starters their talk began in the
past realm where both of them were just
kids sitting in shiganshina like they
used to
i think this might be the same riverbank
where armin first told aaron about the
wonders of the outside world
including things such as the oceans
mountains deserts and what he described
as fire water
as their conversation in parts continued
both of them progressively got older
whilst aaron used his powers to show his
friend different locations from his
grandfather's book
it was quite funny watching armin get so
mesmerized that he lost focus
but throughout the discussion we found
out why mikasa is the real main
character
a couple chapters ago zeke and armin
questioned why ymir remained in the past
dimension
for 2 000 years with zeke theorizing it
was because she still felt attached to
the real world
as he said that this panel showed us a
flashback to your mia's childhood where
she watched on as a couple got married
and kissed each other
in yamir's mind this image of two people
kissing is likely what she thought true
love looked like
and it was something she never received
herself while she may have loved king
fritz
he showed on countless occasions that he
didn't care for especially when he made
their children eat her body
in spite of that she remained loyal to
him for all that time due to this
strange obsessive love in her heart
you may remain connected to every aldian
because she was waiting for someone to
free her from her love for king fritz
and according to erin the person she was
waiting for was mikasa
from the beginning mikasa has had an
unwavering love for aaron possibly even
the same type of love that kept ymir
attached to fritz for two thousand years
the founder likely saw some of herself
in mikasa but of course the two of them
made drastically different choices in
life
whereas emir chose to be a slave who
sacrificed herself in fritz's defense
mikisel was reluctantly able to look
past that love and kill aaron for the
good of humanity
i think you may have smiled in this
scene because this kiss shows her that
what these two had is true love
much like what she witnessed when she
was a child killing aaron naturally also
had the benefit of killing the parasite
founding titan
as it was no longer able to survive
without a host levi correctly assumed
this would happen
and by doing this the power of the
titans was finally eradicated from the
world
this was something that i and i think a
lot of people theorize might happen at
the end of the series
but to be honest i thought it would
happen in a different way i always
thought yamir herself would be the one
to willingly get rid of the power of the
titans
but i'm not mad that it went down this
way instead with mikasa killing aaron
it's just different to what i always
imagined
what was great about this was that after
the titans disappeared the memories that
had previously been wiped out by the
founding titan began to reappear
earlier in the chapter the only reason
we had never seen this flashback
conversation before
is because aaron had erased it from
armin's memory this happened all the way
back in chapter 131
when army was on the boat but until now
we never knew they began immediately
talking after that
with titans now permanently eradicated
aliens have become regular humans just
like everyone else
and as such their memory can no longer
be manipulated by the founding titan
that's the reason why everyone's
memories are coming back and from this
we realized that aaron didn't just talk
to armin but he used his abilities to
have one-to-one conversations with
rainer
connie jean annie and obviously mikasa
he knew their memory would return once
this was all over
so he used it as an opportunity to say
goodbye while we saw his talk with armin
at the beginning of the finale
i believe we already saw erin's
conversation with mikasa in the
penultimate chapter
in this vision the two of them happily
lived together in the mountains
and the idea is that this is what life
would have been like if mikuza had made
a different choice
i'll explain why this is not a dream but
rather the real thing happening in the
past dimension
and there's only one place to start the
moment aaron activated the rumbling
mikasa wondered what would have happened
if she made a different choice so he
created a reality in paths where they
could live out those final years
to show her what it could have been like
when he spoke to armin he showed him a
world of epic landscapes like they
talked about when they were kids
so it means that for each person erin
spoke to he used his powers to show them
different things that were relevant to
them
we know for a fact that time passes
differently in paths i mean zeke felt
like he was there for years but in
reality it had been like one second in
the real world
so clearly these two could have spent a
very long time in there
in chapter one aaron saw mika is saying
goodbye to him in the past dimension
and he saw this from a first person
perspective this perspective means that
aaron was seeing the world through the
eyes of his future self
and this wasn't simply just a random
dream that he and mikasa both just
happen to have
the time they spent living in the
mountains was a real thing that really
happened in nepal's dimension
i'm pretty sure of that i mean it would
have been weird for the series to end
just showing us aaron's conversation
with armin and not mikasa
but let me know in the comments what you
think about this but i'm pretty sure
this is what isayama is trying to convey
here
throughout the series aaron has done a
lot of things he didn't want to do we
have noticeable examples being him
telling his friends he hated them
and killing carla he did these things to
get everyone to this inevitable result
where he dies and armin saves the world
but he never wanted this to happen
in this panel he straight up says he
doesn't want to die and he'd rather be
with mikasa and everyone else
but he knows the future like this isn't
possible that's why he told mikasa in
the past realm to forget about him and
move on
even though he secretly wants her to
keep thinking about him this just shows
you how much of a conflicted person erin
has truly become i mean ever since he
knew the future
he's always just been saying things he
didn't mean to achieve a final result
whether it be his lies to zeke about
wanting to eradicate the alien race
whether it be his lies to the igress
about truly wanting to take over the
island
even knowing he was going to die all the
lies to his best friend saying he hated
them you know the only person who knew
the whole truth all along
was aaron mentally speaking that would
have a lot of negative effects on
anyone and army even says you know it's
been so long that he's been alone
so that's why he's become what he is
this dialogue here from aaron did seem
quite out of character
but given the way his head has been
messed up it is understandable why he's
just you know
not sounding like himself next up now
that the titans are no longer a thing
life could literally not get any better
for the warriors of mali remember how
gabby was desperate to inherit the
armored titan since she thought that
being a warrior was the only way to
prove she was a good aldian
as a regular human being she no longer
has to prove anything to anyone
and can live a full long life just like
falco wanted all along
pique is another warrior who greatly
benefited because the main thing she
wanted to show her father
was that aliens have a bright future
which they now do thanks to this curse
finally being lifted
annie and weiner got their parents back
after they were turned into pure titans
and of course the same could be said for
connie who was waiting for his mother to
be transformed for years now
it's hard to believe she was just inches
away from inheriting the colossal titan
i'm kind of interested to see what that
timeline would have been like at the
beginning of this video i mentioned how
the end of the series was realistic
and one of the reasons i said that was
because without titans or titan shifters
it does make sense that the jaegers
would seek to build their army using
traditional weapons
in season 4 we saw how instructor shadis
was still stuck in the past
and was focusing on how to kill pure
titans while the yeagers were the ones
who were thinking about the future
and how to defeat their enemies outside
the island therefore it seems like
natural progression that this would
happen
though i wasn't liking their sinister
version of the wings of freedom
speaking of wings the final pages will
inevitably bring up that question of
whether or not eren has reincarnated as
a bird or indeed several different birds
birds have always had a special place in
this story because like falco implied
their wings can take them anywhere they
want to go
so they're not confined by the walls or
the gates of an internment zone
or the wars that eldons were sent to
fight in they are the representation of
what freedom is to someone like eren
because like he said
the freest person in the world is the
person who can go to all these different
places
and that's what birds can do now
ordinarily i would say there's a pretty
low chance that aaron was seriously
reincarnated as a bird but there are two
reasons why i'm not ruling it out
reason number one i briefly already
mentioned i mean the idea that aaron
would promise to always write mika's
scarf around her
and then in the final chapter a bird
comes along and does exactly that with
perfect timing
yeah it is a bit suspicious in a series
where you have a giant parasite that can
turn humans into titans
and even resurrect titans of the past i
think reincarnation is not that
far-fetched of a theory
reason number two is like owen said he
didn't know exactly how things were
going to play out after he died
because he can't see further into the
future than his own death while it could
be a coincidence
i feel like isaiah is leaving this to
our interpretation so if you want to
believe that aaron
really is that bird then i guess you can
but yeah it's meant to be open-ended so
there is no definitive answer
some other cool things i liked about the
finale included army playing the role of
the savior
as this was basically a callback to
season three when aaron predicted this
same thing
but in a different context levi seeing
the vestiges of irwin and hanji was also
a pretty cool
send-off moment and it's kind of sad
that all of these characters we love had
to die
to reach this end result another thing i
realized was how ironic this scene has
become
now that we know that eren caused
carla's death this guy really asked
reiner why his mother was killed
and let him take the blame for it
knowing full well that he was going to
be the one responsible
it also turned out the historious baby
really was the child of the farmer
i initially thought there was an element
of mystery there but as time progressed
you know the child became more and more
irrelevant to be honest
so the fact that it was the farmer's
child doesn't really make a difference
anyway guys those are my thoughts on the
final chapter of attack on titan
let me know how you interpreted the
finale down below and tell me where does
this rank for you in terms of your
all-time favorite series
thanks for watching as always and until
the next one peace out